enchanted toilets frozen Easter eggs and
shirtless scenes are just some of the
deleted scenes and rejected concepts
from Disney's live-action Beauty and the
Beast
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to reveal
some of the scenes and ideas that were
cut from 2017 s beauty in the Beast
movie just before I start on giving away
a second copy of this amazing Disney
hardback book from DK which is loaded
with behind the scenes artwork photos
and information about Disney's
live-action and animated movies for a
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe and leave a comment about the
new Beauty the Beast movie or the
deleted scenes on this video and for
bonus ways to enter check out the gleam
link in the video description below a
quick warning there will be spoilers in
this video so just be aware of that or
you can watch life spoiler free review
here and come back after you've seen the
movie when I interviewed beauty in the
Beast director Bill Condon he told me
all about a funny deleted scene that
involved with foo and a new enchanted
character called the fear toilette and
which took place during the battle
between the enchanted objects and the
villagers as a beast castle if you
recall leading up to the battle the foo
had already begun to question his
allegiance to Gaston and in the deleted
scene he opened one of the castles door
to hide away from the fighting
unfortunately full of food behind this
particular door is an enchanted bathroom
and Monsieur toilette attacks him
drenching him with water later when the
household objects changed back to human
form
Monsieur toilette who's played by
Stephen Merchant feels disgusted that
he's had to spend ten years as an
enchanted toy list and he shares another
funny moment with Josh guards Lefou
director Bill Condon explained that the
Masuya Twilight scene was cut both the
time and also because the humor was
considered a bit lowbrow in comparison
to the rest of the scene the fascial
scene also had other moments cut
including one word the enchanted stove
attacks the village lasses which is what
the bimbettes are called in the
live-action movie and just before the
battle Gaston rallies the villagers with
the rousing mob song as well as some
altered lyrics you might have noticed
that there's a section of the song
missing from the theatrical release you
can listen to the missing lyrics by Luke
Evans Josh GAD and The Villages on the
official soundtrack but the deleted
section is from a scene on the way to
the castle with a mob creep past the
wolf singing we don't like what we don't
understand in fact it scares us and this
monster is mysterious at least Bill
Condon was
to cut this scene as it was so beautiful
but explained that it ended up
downplaying the tension of the moment
and will also cut the time given how
incredibly popular Disney's animated
Beauty in the Beast movie is and the
fact that it went to Oscars for its
music it seems unbelievable that early
in development the studio wanted to
completely overhaul the story and cut
out all the songs apparently at the time
the studio wanted to go in a similar
direction to the 2012 movie Snow White
and the Huntsman which starred Kristen
Stewart it wasn't until the huge success
of frozen in 2013 the Disney realized
there was enormous potential in a
musical remake
however the studio was still unsure and
wanted to do just half the songs from
the original movie director Bill Condon
who has a strong musical background with
films like Chicago and Dreamgirls
refused to take on the project until
Disney recognized that a full-on musical
was the best approach I absolutely love
Alan Menken and Howard Ashman songs from
the 1991 film so really glad that the
studio did come to its senses and go for
a proper musical movie in the end and
even added some new songs by Menken and
Tim Rice speaking of music and
live-action remakes of Disney movies
it'll be interesting to see just how
much music actually makes it into the
live-action version of Mulan as director
Niki Caro first said there wouldn't be
any songs but later said there will be
music when I interviewed Emma Watson and
Dan Stevens about the movie they
explained that there were plans for a
scene involving Belle where she
convinced these to convert his vast
personal library into a public space or
public library Belle wanted to open up
the knowledge to the whole world and it
was also going to be a place where she
could combine her passion for books and
teaching and educating others much as we
see her do at the beginning of the movie
Emma Watson said she was gutted when the
Public Library idea didn't make it into
the final film but according to Dan
Stevens there wasn't room for it in the
shape of the final story there's also a
picture of a deleted scene between Belle
and the beggar woman Agatha who's The
Enchantress in disguise and this scene
looks like it probably happened early in
the movie by the way if you'd like to
discover all the secrets of the new
live-action enchantress then tap in the
top right of the screen to check out my
video there's a wonderful moment in the
original movie were Lefou gets covered
in snow like a snowman outside Belle's
house Josh GAD who plays with foo and is
the voice of Olaf the snowman in frozen
he begged bill condon to include the
scene in the live-action movie as it's
such a great easter egg an in-joke for
Disney fans suddenly the scene never
made it into the final film perhaps
because it wouldn't have fit into the
new version because there was no need
for the food to spy on Belle's house as
he did in the animation in the final
transformation scene where beef turns
back into the prince then Stephens
reportedly filmed scenes where he was
shirtless and rose up from a layer of
rose petals rather different then to
Charlotte scene in the horror thriller
the guests during Beauty and the Beast
test screenings though it was felt that
the way the scene was shot made it look
like Dan Stevens was perhaps fully naked
so the scene ended up being cut and Luke
Evans explains at the moment in the
original animation where Gaston reveals
that every last inch of him is covered
with her was also cut because it wasn't
considered family-friendly enough now
I'd love to know what you thought about
the deleted scenes which didn't make it
into the final movie and is there
anything from the original film you
which had been included don't forget to
comment and subscribe for your chance to
win a second copy of this awesome Disney
hardback book and if you enjoyed this
I'd really appreciate your likes and
shares and you can tap or click here to
watch more of my beauty in the Beast
videos including my Disney Theory video
about The Enchantress and my video with
Easter eggs and things you missed in a
new movie thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers